we're taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 a lot of very very interesting
questions so far let's go next to our
caller from the 831 area code who's
calling today from 831 yes that's you
but I can barely hear you do that letter
yeah that's better who's this hi this is
Gavin Eldridge I'm a college student
right now majoring in computer science
alright and I had kind of a insight into
the college ecosystem but I don't think
anyone's really addressing really and
that is the whole structure of the te
college system GE meaning general
education and I basically think that
it's requiring a lot of students to have
to take a lot of classes that they
really don't need for they degree and
it's kind of somewhat of an elitist
strategy that keeps like maybe we'll
really income students out and so let's
explore that why why do gen ed
requirements keep low-income students
out of college how why how does that
happen well personally I'm pretty
fortunate I was performing that's
willing to pay for my college and like
my living situation books etc but I
understand that it can be extremely
pricey and our friends who struggle with
this all the time right
I see like me taking things like that
class and like anthropology and all it's
super interesting as no relevant or very
little relevant we think you do science
and I was struggling with money idea
Gavin let me I'm sorry to interrupt
Gavin you it's sounding like you're
putting a towel over the phone or maybe
going underwater while you talk to me I
think I understand what you're
I mean listen my view on gen ed required
requirements is that the a lot of what
you learn in college is you learn how to
think and you learn about people and
relationships and the world and my
experience with general education
requirements at the undergraduate level
and even sort of like more general
requirements at the graduate level still
within my field but maybe not my
specialty like when I was doing my
master's degree is that those are really
useful classes in understanding sort of
how society works how culture works and
I I don't you know there may be specific
options for some of these classes that
seem particularly irrelevant but I think
that the the there's a that gen Ed's are
really important and what we want we
want people to not just go to college
and learn coding we want people to go to
college and learn more about society and
people in the world I 100% agree I think
that they are useful in their own right
I just think that they should be
structured in a way that allows the
individual take the classes that would
benefit them most well so maybe this
differs at each school but like when I
was an undergrad at UMass I had there
were often dozens of classes that were
available to meet each general education
requirement I wasn't you know there were
some exceptions like everybody had to
take sophomore writing and it was
basically the same class for everybody
but most of the gen ed requirements you
had a lot of choice but maybe this you
know there's thousands of colleges and
universities it may not be the same at
everyone yeah all right thank you
take care great to hear from you